why are you the only man who wants to  stay with me  um  thank you too  i do  that's good  why is mom so different around other  people  i think this is who she is  you love me  of course  you're not born  no  the fact that she's comfortable floating  all these relationships around all of us  you're better than that  she's different  [Music]  that's what i like about her  [Music]  [Applause]  i just want to feel joy in my life  you want to tell me why you didn't come  home last night not really  this isn't a game melinda  it's always been a game  [Music]  [Applause]  the truth is  [Applause]  if you were married to anyone else  you'd be so bored  you kill yourself  do you think we'll ever be just happy  god i hope so  you